j'inviterais donc les représentants des
deux parties à bien vouloir procéder à
cette signature c'était le 23 octobre
2000 par
nos façons
les braves la paix des braves est le
premier traité moderne entre le québec
est une nation autochtone les québécois
les québécoises et les hommes et les
femmes formant la nation crie pose un
geste qui va lui dans le sens de
l'harmonie c'est une enfant en tant qu'
à l'époque était révolutionnaire on peut
le dire d'une part au niveau symbolique
en le changement de ton on parle la paix
des braves on parle de paix c'est pas
pour rien c'est parce qu'il y avait
vraiment un conflit dans les dix années
qui précédaient la entre le québec et
les cris à l'époque des milliards de
dollars en poursuite sont en jeu
québec vous voulez développer les
ressources naturelles de la baie james
et nous voulions bénéficient des
retombées économiques explique ted
meneuse grand chef du grand conseil des
cris homologue du premier ministre de
l'époque bernard landry
après quelques mois de négociations le
gouvernement s'engage à consulter les
cris pour les projets de développement
économique à venir dans la région
l'entente garantie entre autres que la
nation autochtone recevra 4 milliards de
dollars en 50 ans pour gérer le
développement de ces communautés jean st
gelais qui était à l'époque secrétaire
général du québec estime que la proches
des deux parties a été la clé de leur
succès ont décidé de faire sur une base
du respect mutuel que ce n'est pas m
québec criq à manger quoi faire avec
l'argent qui était impliqué la banque
c'est la notion de nation a été
excessivement important dans l'entente
l'entente qui a permis la construction
des centrales hydroélectrique eastmain a
aussi changé la destinée des communautés
cries et qui met les gens
nous communautés sont prospère grâce à
la paix des braves dit il depuis la paix
des braves il est impensable de faire du
développement économique dans le nord du
québec sans le consentement des cris et
le partage de bénéfices avec lui cette
façon de faire est devenu un modèle dans
les relations entre le gouvernement et
les peuples autochtones ici valérie
michaela ben haddou canada montréal